Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Schön. Das Problem ist aber in der Tat, also macht sowas in Zukunft vielleicht ein bisschen vorsichtiger, weil wenn sowas da draufklebt, die Leute, die das bedienen, die sind in der Regel nicht sehr weit. Und wenn man sowas feststellt und sowas in der Hand hat, vorsichtig wieder ran kleben, sich von dem Ding entfernen und erst mal irgendwie Polizei oder so, weil Gefahr für Leib und Leben ist dann das vielleicht auch nicht wert an der Stelle.
Ja und vor allem, man kriegt sie ja nicht, wenn man aufs fällig das Ding abholt, klar, dann sehen die, das hat einer aufgedeckt und dann hauen die ab, das wollte ich sagen.
Im Idealfall, also im Worst Case kriegst du eins aufs Maul und die nehmen das Ding wieder mit, weil sie natürlich das Ding nicht hinterlassen wollen, weil das Ding teuer war.
Also diese Sparkasse mit Doppelklebeband werbe ich meine, die Rentner haben es ja eh alle noch nicht verstanden, aber irgendwie werden doch so langsam mal alle Leute dafür sensibilisiert, dass wenn einem einem Automaten irgendwas dran ist, dran gebastelt haben könnte, dass man dann aufmerksam wird. Und die Sparkasse baut eigene Werbetafeln mit Doppelklebeband auf ihre Automaten neben das Pinsel. Ich meine, das wird man doch in Hintern treten, sondern gleich, oder?
Aber das war Potsch dann, oder?
In einem deutschen Bankautomaten, dass mir die Blende vor dem Karten in dieser in die Hand gefallen ist. Ich dachte mir, hey, cool, ein Skimmer. Aber es war dann tatsächlich nur ein Plastikteil, was an der Stelle schlecht montiert war. Ich hab das denen dann in der Bank in die Hand gedrückt. Hier hätte auch ein Skimmer sein können. Ich wollte ja nicht mal eure Automaten austauschen. Das ist wohl mal echt unter eurer Würde. Die wussten aber interessanterweise schon, was ich mit Skimmer meine. Also die Sensibilisierung ist da. Aber in der Ausführung hapert es dann manchmal so ein bisschen.
Christoph, vielen Dank für diese sehr schöne Geschichte. Und wir werden die Zukunft alle mal nach Holzleisten ausverhalten und Bohrungen.
Als es um die ganzen Skimming-Nummern angeht, da gibt es in der Tat Koordinierungen zwischen den Banken. Es gibt den sogenannten EKS Pool, findet man unter eks-net.de. Darüber tauschen sich die Banken aus, was für Fälle es gegeben hat, und koordinieren sich auch, was die Schadensregulierung und so weiter angeht. Also die sprechen da schon miteinander über das Problem und gucken halt auch, dass wenn ein Kunde so was moniert, ob das ungefähr in das Petern reinpasst, was sie da haben. Nachrichtigen da auch Kunden proaktiv, wenn so was vorgefallen ist und da andere Kunden noch mit an dem Geldautomaten waren und sie wissen, da gab es einen Skimming-Fall, dann wird sich da ausgetauscht.
Gibt es denn eigentlich so, wonach guckt man denn da? Weil ich stehe oft vor so einem Geldautomaten, also ich kenne ja meinen Geldautomaten, wo ich immer hingehe, da fällt mir natürlich auf, wenn der sich erinnert. Aber ich stehe oft vor Geldautomaten, denke so, das sieht jetzt ganz schön abgegrabbelt aus und die Tastatur ist auch echt tief eingelassen. Also möglicherweise hat er ja was gebaut, aber das sind dann doch immer die richtigen. Aber gibt es so Dinge, wie man das erkennen kann?
Ja, es ist schwer. Am besten sich vielleicht wirklich mal im Internet, Google, Bildersuche, Skimmer, ATM, Skimmer, sich das mal anzuschauen, dass man ein Gefühl dafür kriegt, wie so Zeug aussieht. Es gibt bei neueren Automaten Anti-Skimming-Einrichtungen. Das sind so grüne Plastikaufsätze, die an der Stelle eine Aussparung haben, wo der Magnetstreifen ist. Das heißt, wenn man da einen Skimmer draufsetzen würde, dann würde man sehen, dass das nicht Teil dieses transparenten grünen Sicherheitsplastiks ist. Dann gibt es zusätzlich noch in den Automaten Sicherheitsmechanismen. Ich weiß nicht, ob sowas deploit wurde, aber ich habe gelesen, das war ein Paper, das sich damit beschäftigt hat, wie man dagegen vorgehen kann. Die überprüfen, ob irgendwie vor dem Schlitz irgendwas ist, also die mit Sensorik das überprüfen. Ja, aber in der Regel einfach den Geldschlitz sich angucken, ob man das Gefühl hat, dass irgendwas da vorgesetzt ist oder ob der...
Okay, also merken wir mal, Google-Sucher, ATM-Skimmer. ATM ist das Englische für Geldautomaten, dann kann man vielleicht mal ein bisschen was sehen.
So, das ist tierisch spannend, weil da echt viel schicke Technologie und auch krass Low-Tech, also von irgendwie 20 Euro Supermarkt, Plastik, Mini-Kameras, die auseinandergefrimmelt und die Platine dann mit einem Kabel verlängert und um die Ecke bis hin zu, also da gibt es die abenteuerlichsten Konstrukte für sowas, weil sowas natürlich auch immer nicht teuer sein darf, wenn man viele davon deploiten und zurücklassen möchte. Also das ist unglaublich erfinderisch. Und eine der neueren, die sind inzwischen auch schon ein bisschen angeheitert, ist Cash Trapping, was so eine Blende vor den Geldausgabe schlitz, wo die Noten rauskommen, dass er in der Regel so ein kleines Rolladentürchen, was aufgeht und wieder zugeht. Und da setzen so eine identisch aussehende Blende davor mit einem Kleber dahinter, an dem dann das Geld hängen bleibt. Also das Geld kommt raus, bleibt an diesem Kleber hängen und das Türchen kann nicht zugehen, aber das Geld auch nicht rein, weil der Automat das Geld ja nicht ziehen kann, wenn es noch irgendwo klebt. Und du stehst halt vor dem Automaten und hast das Gefühl, da kommt kein Geld raus, es macht irgendwie Ratsch, Ritter, Ritter, Ritter, so das Geräusch, aber da geht kein Türchen auf und der Schutz dagegen ist total lotig. Sie haben einfach unten an das Türchen noch eine Kante ran gemacht, dass man da nichts aufsetzen kann.
Also ein stetes Geben und Nehmen an Neuentwicklungen, am Geldautomaten. Ich gebe die Hoffnung nicht auf, dass wir in dieser Sendung noch zu bargeldlosen Transferdingern kommen. Ich würde jetzt gerne...
Ich würde gerne sagen, das ging in die richtige Richtung, weil das ist in der Tat so ein Ansatz, diesen Übergang in ein Peer-to-Peer-System zu gehen.
Was ich gerne noch mal wissen würde, ist, wie das ist mit Prepaid-Kreditkarten, also anders formuliert anonyme Kreditkarten. Gibt es sowas? Wenn ja, wie macht man das und wird sich das durchsetzen?
Da ich gerade eine in der Hand habe, kann ich ja vielleicht kurz dazu was sagen. Das gibt's, kommt von Visa. In dem Fall ist die bei irgendeiner Tankstelle gekauft, lag da einfach in den Prepaid-Karten mit rum. Also da, wo man sozusagen seine 20 Euro Aufladekarten fürs Handy kaufen kann, lag die dazwischen. Hat 10 Euro gekostet, die erste Aufladung irgendwie an der Kasse war umsonst. Muss man im Internet einmal am besten über ein Proxietor oder irgendwie sonst wie geheim aktivieren. Muss keine Daten abgeben.
Du kaufst die Karte und kaufst dann noch einen Gutscheincode oder wie?
Genau, die Karte kostet einmal 10 Euro. Die ist dann noch nichts wert mit, der kann nicht zahlen. Und ab dem Augenblick, wo ich sie im Internet registriert habe, kann ich dann hier eine Telefonnummer anrufen oder entsprechende Guthaben kurz kaufen und die, wie bei einem prepaid Handy, draufladen. 50 Euro draufladen oder 100. Einige Tankstellen bieten das an. Tankstellen versuchen ja mittlerweile den Geldautomaten auch Konkurrenz zu machen, nämlich das komische Geldhandling-System jetzt, wo man an der Tankstelle irgendwie Geld abheben kann. Und da kann man jetzt auch die Kreditkarte an der Tankstellenkasse dann auffüllen.
Möglich gemacht hat das eine Urteil, was es gab. Das ging durch viele Instanzen, weil das natürlich schon sehr praktisch ist, ja so prepaid Bezahlkarten zu haben, das ist ein unglaublicher Markt gerade ja für das untere Drittel der Transaktionen vom Volumen her. Und ja, letztenstens wurde dann da festgelegt, dass sowas in Deutschland legal ist, ohne Registrierung des Teilnehmers, der diese Karte besitzt, bis 150 Euro. Also das ist die Grenze, bis zu der uns sozusagen zugestanden wird, anonym mit digitalen Bezahlkarten.
Und das heißt, mehr kriegt man dann nicht drauf auf so einer Pre-Bate-Karte?
Richtig, genau. Das ist der juristische Rahmen. Ab dem Rahmen müsste man dann eine Registrierung vornehmen. Und das ist natürlich dann wieder ein anderes Produkt.
Stichwort an der Stelle Geldwäsche.
Genau.
Weil ganz klar, Geld, das fließt, muss natürlich kontrolliert werden. Weil wenn es in zu großen Mengen fließt, könnte ich damit ja meine illegal von meinen Parteifreunden eingesammelten Spenden irgendwie waschen.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Niemand, niemand, niemand.
Gut, dass wir darüber geredet haben.
Gibt es auch in anderen Ländern, das sind die klassischen Gift Cards. Also da hat man eine Geschenkkarte, die man irgendwie verschenken kann mit einem Guthaben drauf, was halt eine ganz normale Zahnkarte ist.
Was halt ziemlich aufwendig ist, wenn man 5 Millionen Euro Drogengeld irgendwann seine Lieblingspartei spenden möchte. Und jetzt geht man zum nächstgelegenen Baumarkt und kauft dort für besagtes Bargeld entsprechende Gutscheinkarten. In jeweils Höhe von 25 oder 50 Euro hat man dann hinterher doch einen größeren Container voll mit so kleinen Karten und...
Also wichtig war es, glaube ich, einfach nur, dass deutlich in der Entfernung zur Geldwäschegesetzhürde von 15.000 Euro, also ab 15.000 Euro ist eine Transaktion Geldwäschegesetz relevant. Und dass man einfach ganz weit davon entfernt bleibt. Und das wirklich nur für den, ja...
Okay, also anonym mit Plastigeld bezahlt. Also einsetzen tut man wie eine normale Kreditkarte, also wenn ich damit bezahle.
Ist eine richtige Kreditkarte, bloß es nicht personengebezogen ist.
Das geht also. Die andere Frage, die ich hatte, ist, wie sieht es denn jetzt aus? Kunde mit Händler geht? Wie ist es denn Kunde mit Kunde? Also wie kann ich dem Nibbler jetzt irgendwie zwei Euro für ein Döner geben? Okay, ich habe kein Bargeld mehr, sondern möchte das gerne... Leute, macht es mir nicht so schwer hier heute. Nein, also ernsthaft, gibt es dann...
Ich nehme auch deine Kreditkarten nochmal.
Nein, ich möchte dir meine Kreditkartennummer nicht geben.
Und die, die hinten drauf steht.
Ich würde dem Nibbler jetzt auch zutrauen, dass er das Geld kriegt, ohne dass er die Nummer von dir verdient. Aber unheimlich davon.
Ich habe heute gelernt, ich gebe dir nicht meine Nummer. Nein.
Es gab da mal den Politiker, der behauptet hat, irgendwie das deutsche Bankensystem sei so sicher, dass er auf einer großen Pressekonferenz unbedingt seine Kontonummer jetzt erzählen muss. Schön. Es waren drei Stunden oder so, bis sein Konto leer war.
Wobei das wahrscheinlich Lastschrift an der Stelle war. Das ist auch eine speziell deutsche Geschichte. Das gibt es auch in anderen Ländern. Aber generell Lastschrift, dass man eben nur mit dem Wissen einer Kontonummer und einer Bankleitzahl Geld einziehen kann.
Lastschrift kann man immer zurückrufen.
Innerhalb von sechs Wochen.
Genau.
Das waren keine Lastschriften. Der Spaß an der Sache war, es waren tatsächlich Überweisungen, die nicht rückrufbar waren an gemeinnützige Organisationen. Und da war das Geld echt los.
Das wüsste ich gerne, wie das funktioniert hat.
Ehrlich gesagt wüsste ich das auch nicht.
Es gab immer mal wieder Berichte über Überweisungsträger auf Papier, die ausgefüllt wurden, wo dann auch irgendwie so mit XXX und Dagobert Duck unterschrieben wurden und die dann irgendwie trotzdem durchgehen.
Da wird ja inzwischen auch nicht mehr der Name geprüft. Bei kleinen Überweisungen?
Also es wurde fandet auf den kleinen Überweisungsträgern wurde noch nie kontrolliert, irgendwie unterhalb einer gewissen Summe, was da wirklich draufsteht. Es gab da mal die Idee, dass man Denial-of-Service-Attacken gegen Banken fahren kann, in dem jeder allen seinen Freunden 5 Cent auf einem Papierträger überweist. Die Bank ist verpflichtet, das innerhalb von drei Tagen auszuführen. Das ist so eines der netten Bankengesetzes. Wir haben also Banken müssen innerhalb von drei Tagen operabel sein. Also sie müssen Überweisungen ausführen, gegenüber dem Kunden, aber auch gegenüber anderen Banken. Deswegen mögen Banken es nicht, wenn sie drei Tage gar nichts können. Und sie dann komplett so zu überlasten und sie dann hinterher dafür anzuklagen, dass sie irgendwie diese drei Cent nicht an ihnen überwiesen haben. War mal so eine Idee, die wahrscheinlich Gott sei Dank auch nicht gemacht wurde, weil, wie wir jetzt in den letzten zwei Jahren ja mehrfach gelernt haben, Banken sind systemkritisch.
In der Tat. Und deswegen würde ich jetzt schon wieder gerne zum Thema kommen. Wie ist denn das eigentlich, Leute untereinander Geld überweisen, ohne den Umweg, zwischen eine Bank oder eine Händler oder irgendwas zu machen? Geht das? Gibt es da Ideen zu?
Da gab es mal ganz viel. Also es gab so Sachen wie zum Beispiel diese Geschenkkarten und Ähnliches. Das heißt, ich kann sozusagen Wert, also was ist Geld? Geld ist sozusagen eine metaphysische Abstraktion von meistens Arbeitsleistung, weil dem Gold ist es egal, wem es besitzt, nur der Goldschürfer, der findet es spannend. Das heißt, ich habe sozusagen eine Metaeinheit von einer gewissen Arbeitsleistung, die kann ich hin und her schieben. Und irgendwie brauche ich einen Token, ein Stück, das diesen Wert versinnbildlich, das vertrauenswürdig ist und das ich hin und her schieben kann. Das heißt, das war früher mal ein Stückchen Gold, dann war es so ein Stückchen Papier und jetzt ist es halt so ein Stückchen Plastik, naja, da ist es nicht mehr das Geld, das muss man halt auch an der Stelle immer wieder sagen. Das ist halt nur das Verrechnungssystem, mit dem am Hintergrund wiederum Zahlen hin und her geschoben werden, die jetzt das Geld darstellen. Das heißt, wenn du an einen Freund Geld geben möchtest, dann musst du etwas suchen, was so viel Wert hat, dass es der Freund einfach gegen etwas tauschen kann, was ihm was wert ist. Das heißt, wenn der Freund jetzt zum Beispiel Hunger hat, dann solltest du ihm etwas geben, womit er in der Lage ist, sich einen Döner zu kaufen. Das kannst du zum Beispiel tun, indem du anfängst World of Warcraft zu spielen. Und wenn du bei World of Warcraft genügend Monster gekillt hast, oder irgendein anderes dieser Online-Spiele, genügend Monster gekillt hast, dann hast du ganz viel Gold und das Gold kannst du eintauschen gegen wahre Münze. Was übrigens sehr spannend ist an der Stelle meine Buchempfehlung. Das neueste Buch von Neil Stevenson, Reamde, also sozusagen Read Me falsch geschrieben, geht komplett um den Fall, dass der Inhaber einer solchen Online-Spiele-Bude ehemaliger Drogenschmuggler und ansonsten natürlich auch die super coole Typen vom Herrn wird in einen Erpressungsfall hineingezogen, wo es darum geht, dass den Leuten per Trojaner ihr Rechner verschlüsselt wird und die sollen dann in diesem Online-Spiel irgendwo hingehen, an eine bestimmte Stelle, sollen dort einen bestimmten Spielgeldbetrag vergaben, damit der Trojaner-Schreiber dann an dieser Stelle mit seinen Leuten wiederum das Spielgeld ausgräbt und dann über die entsprechenden Vermittlungsstellen aus dem Spielgeld wieder reales Geld macht. Und das geht überall. Das heißt, ich habe überall diese Vermittlungsstellen von Leuten, die bereit sind, Spielgeld anzunehmen und dafür reales Geld auszuzahlen oder reales Geld anzunehmen und dafür Spielgeld auszuzahlen.
Jetzt möchte ich aber, wenn ich auf einem offenen sozusagen unterwegs bin und dem Libler Döner ausgeben will, ja nicht meinen World of Warcraft anwerfen.
Warum nicht?
Weil das ganz schön lange dauern würde, bis man den Gegenwert eines Ich nenne auch keine Second Life Linden Dollars. So sieht es aus.
Das heißt, die sind auch echt alt.
Gibt es da, also ich fühle mich vorhin schon mal der Begriff Google Wallet, gibt es da irgendwie so Technologien, die ein bisschen praktikabler sich zumindest anhören?
Das wird kommen. Also gerade Google Wallet und dann gibt es von Google jetzt auch die Brille und es gibt noch ein zweites Buch, das total empfehlenswert ist, nämlich Demon von einem Herrn Suarez aus Amerika. Da haben wir dann alle diese Brillen auf, die bei Google jetzt ja auch bald kommen. Und über diese Brillen siehst du dann, wer Nibbler in einer zweiten Realität, also sprich in der Online-Welt, in dem Multi-User-Spiel dahinter ist und kannst ihn sozusagen nur durch angucken und zweimal blinzeln im dahinter gelegten Google Wallet das Spielgeld geben. Und er blinzelt dann den Dönerverkäufer an, der hat auch so eine Brille an. Und dann ist das Geld bezahlt, der Dönerverkäufer gibt das Geld rüber. Das ist Science Fiction, aber es ist insofern Science Fiction als, also nicht Science Fiction. Die Technik ist da, die Zahlungssysteme da, sind da, Google Wallet gibt's. Was im Prinzip auch nichts anderes ist, als ein namensbasiertes Zahlungssystem, das wiederum gegen eine Kreditkarte gesichert ist. Und die Kommunikationsformen sind auch da, das heißt die Möglichkeit sich zu sehen. Die Brille kommt gerade und das Buch, das das alles beschreibt, wie das dann mal alles so richtig gut wird und sozusagen die neue IT Revolution, den Planeten damit herrschen wird, heißt Demon von Suarez.
So und jetzt noch mal einen Schritt zurück und ein Schritt praktikabler, also realer, dieses Google Wallet. Ist das tatsächlich sozusagen so eine Science Fiction Brille oder ist das, ich habe irgendwas mit Handys im Hinterkopf, Handys, die man aneinander hält und dann wird irgendwie...
Also Google Wallet ist erstmal eine Handy Applikation, die auf Checkout basiert. Das heißt, erstmal habe ich Checkout und Checkout ist das Online Zahlungssystem von Google. Wenn ich bei Google im Market oder sonst wo irgendwas zahlen möchte, dann mache ich das über Checkout. Und Wallet ist die Schnittstelle zwischen Checkout über diese Near Field Communication, das heißt wiederum über eine Funkschnittstelle, die nur im Nahbereich funktioniert, zum Zahlterminal des Händlers. Also auch hier kein Peer-to-Peer, also aktuell Wallet, kein Peer-to-Peer. Das heißt, ich habe sozusagen die Möglichkeit, eine App auf meinem Handy zu haben, die diesen eingebauten Funkchip benutzt, um mit dem Funkchip des Händlers in seiner Kasse zu reden und dem Funkchip des Händlers ein Einmalpasswort zu sagen und eine Summe und wer ich eigentlich bin und was ich gerade kaufe und noch ein paar Sachen. Und mit diesem Einmalpasswort und der Summe kann der Händler dann sofort, natürlich online, wahrscheinlich auch über Android, Android for Cachedesks gibt es glaube ich noch nicht, kommt bestimmt irgendwann, dann zu Google gehen und dort das Geld gut geschrieben kriegen und hat dann die Zahlung autorisiert, so wie bei der Kreditkarte auch. Deswegen meinte ich vorhin irgendwie, da ist kein Unterschied. Ich habe wiederum eine Nummer, ich habe wiederum einen Namen, der dahinter steht und ob ich das nun Kreditkarte nenne oder EC-Karte oder Google Wallet oder Paypass oder Sonstiges. Es sind eigentlich nur die Schnittstellentechnologien zwischen dem, der zahlen möchte und autorisiert und dem, der die Zahlung empfängt und dann die Ware oder was auch immer herausgibt.
Das charakterisiert interessant, aber es ist wirklich alle dieses Thema. Sei es World of Warcraft, sei es Second Life oder sonst irgendwelches Geld, dass man sich jetzt auch in irgendwelchen Online-Webgames schenkt dir einen Schaf auf, hast du den nicht gesehen, farm.de. Das wirtschaftliche Interesse ist einfach nicht da. Wir hätten sowas schon sehr viel früher haben können, nämlich bei der unscheinbaren Geldkarte. Die Geldkarte war nämlich tatsächlich ein Ding, worauf mittels eine Authentifizierung Geld auf und abgebucht werden konnte. Das war da auch angedacht und wurden, glaube ich, auf welche ausgegeben, aber wird sich nie so richtig verbreitet, da wirklich eine anonyme nichtkonten- oder kartengebundene Zahlung zu haben. Eine White Card, wo du halt sagst, ich zahle jetzt Geld ein auf diese Karte. Das ist dann auf diesem Geldkarten-Chip und die Idee wäre weiterhin gewesen, dass man von einer Geldkarte auf eine andere Geldkarte Geld übertragen kann. Das war auch spezifiziert, das war mit der Geldkarte gegangen. Aber es gibt schlicht kein wirtschaftliches Interesse dahinter, weil wenn Kunden zwischen einander Geld übertragen, verdient da niemand was dran. Und es gibt einfach kein Unternehmen, was sich da irgendwie den Schuh anziehen möchte und sagen ja finde ich eine gute Sache. Auch Geld verdienen ist jetzt nicht so. Die Leute haben zwar auch andere Bezahlmechanismen, wo wir ein bisschen Geld abgreifen könnten, aber wir sind mal lieb zum Kunden und finden das mit dem Geld von Anach B ganz toll. Also gab da einfach ein wirtschaftliches Interesse dahinter, dass wirklich Kunden miteinander ohne Banken Geld transferieren.
Weil die Banken da schon auch mit dabei sind, muss man bei der Geldkarte, selbst bei Karte-Karte-Zahlung, Geldkarte arbeitet immer mit dem Schattenkonto, das heißt es wird wiederum nur von Karte zu Karte übertragen. Ich verspreche dir zu zahlen um den Hintergrund auf einem Schattenkonto, dass bei den ausgebenden Banken geführt wird, wird die eigentliche Zahlung ausgeführt. Das heißt die Bank weiß, wer wem was gibt.
Das Schattenkonto bei der Geldkarte auch nur nachgezogen wurde, also du kannst mit der Geldkarte schon verbindliche Transaktionen machen, ohne dass das Schattenkonto im Spiel ist. Das Schattenkonto ist wirklich nur da gewesen, um nachzuvollziehen, ob da jetzt irgendwo großer Betrug passiert und an welcher Stelle und dann da mal einzugreifen. Aber es war jetzt nie was, was wirklich für Transaktionen Ausschlag geben würde.
Ist das technisch dasselbe System, was ich in der Mensa habe, wenn ich irgendwie mit so einer, da gibt es ja diese Aufladekarten, wo ich eben Zwangi in den Automaten schiebe und dann ist das so.
Genau das glaube ich auch. Ja, der Unterschied ist, dass bei deiner Mensa Karte deine Mensa Karte meist ein ID-Token ist und dass irgendwo zentral gespeichert wird. Das kommt jetzt auf dieses Thema an. Bei der Geldkarte ist es aber in der Tat so, dass der Betrag auf der Karte tatsächlich gespeichert wird.
Also deine Karte macht aber keinen Unterschied, weil wenn ich meine Geldkarte verliere und da sind noch 20 Euro drauf, dann kriege ich drei Tage später von meiner Bank eine Gutschrift über 20 Euro.
Nein, das ist definitiv weg. Also das Geldkarte ist wie Bargeld gewesen. Definitiv. Also da kriegst du auch von deiner Bank keine Erstattung für, wenn dir die abhanden kommen mit dem Geld drauf.
Das heißt, da war es ein Versuch, aber kein wirtschaftliches Interesse. Jetzt ist ja nicht immer wirtschaftliches Interesse ausschlaggebend an so Dingern. Wir haben zum Beispiel Bitcoin, haben wir schon kurz erwähnt. Da wurde das ja versucht, das will ich jetzt hier nicht noch mal ausführen wollen, weil da gibt es das Chaosradio 169, das kann man sich ja noch mal komplett anhören. Da wird es erklärt, gab es denn noch andere Ansätze, also Community Driven, wie es im Bullshit-Bingo so schön heißt. Gibt es da noch andere Ansätze, sowas zu realisieren? Also sagen jetzt nicht von Banken aus, sondern halt außer, keine Ahnung, dass sich irgendwelche Hacker das ausgedacht haben oder so?
Neues Geld fürs neue Internet. Also wir kommen jetzt an der Stelle auf gerade die Frage, dass irgendwelche Hacker sich ausgedacht haben. Da stellt halt eine grundsätzliche Systemfrage von, was ist eigentlich Geld im Sinne von, wer gibt das eigentlich aus, wer sollte das eigentlich machen? Also wir haben, Entwicklung des Geldes war tatsächlich privatwirtschaftlich. Es gab irgendwie in den USA auch mal so zu Bürgerkriegszeiten, gab sowas wie Free Cat Banks, die haben dann ihr eigenes Geld gedruckt, unabhängig vom Staat und solche Dinge, die haben sich, wurden aber alle vom Staat wieder eingefangen. Und jetzt aktuell leben wir in einer Welt, in der die aktuellen Zahlungssysteme, oder das geht, na nicht die Zahlungssysteme, aber das Geld an sich stark vom Staat kontrolliert wird. Manchmal geht es schief, sie haben wir ja gerade immer in der Presse, aber nicht so so trotz leben wir in einer Welt, die von M1, M2 und M3 regiert wird. Also von den drei Geldmengen, die gerechnet werden. In dem Augenblick, wo Linden, Dollars oder Coins bei Facebook oder irgendwie Gold bei World of Warcraft oder sonstiges eine neue Währung erschaffen, mit der tatsächlich auch gehandelt wird, mit der Leute Dinge zahlen und sei es auch nur ein virtuelles Schaf, aber das Schaf kann man dann mit darum tauschen gegen einen echten Döner vielleicht. Das würde ja auch ganz gut zusammenpassen.
Und dass eine relevante Geräusse übersteigt.
Und eine gewisse Menge einfach an Geld damit transferiert wird, habe ich eine M4. Das heißt eine vierte Geldmenge, die bei den Bundesbanken nicht überwacht wird. Was sind die ersten drei? Das erste ist das Papiergeld, das Bargeld und das Kontokerentgeld oder so. Steht im Internet.
Schön.
Also das Wichtige ist sozusagen, ich habe die drei Geldmengen, die ich habe. Das sind einmal die Gelder, die bei den Banken auf dem Stapel liegen. Die Gelder, die tatsächlich im Bargeld umgelaufen sind. In der Mitte gibt es noch was.
Also um es mal ganz abstrakt zu halten, ist der Staat natürlich daran interessiert, über die Geldmenge, die im Umlauf ist, eine gewisse Kontrolle zu haben. Weil je mehr Geld da ist, das ist die Inflationsgeschichte. Das so weniger ist das Geld in der Theorie wert. Und wenn da jetzt eine Firma kommt, die künstlich Geld erfinden kann, für das man Dinge eingetauscht bekommt, ohne staatliche oder ohne externe Kontrolle, ist natürlich der Anreiz gegeben, dass die von diesem Geld, das sie ja frei produzieren können, mehr produzieren. Und dadurch dann Einfluss auf das wirtschaftliche System haben gegeben. Deswegen ist das ja natürlich sehr schädlich für die Wirtschaft insgesamt, wenn es da nochmal einen dritten Akteur gibt, der sozusagen aus der hohen Hand Geld erzeugen kann. Da ist glaube ich kein Staat oder keine Zentralbank großer Freude darüber.
Aber es stellt halt auch dieses ganze System so ein bisschen in die Frage, weil Geld im Prinzip hat damals mal mit MEVO-Wechseln angefangen, dass wir tatsächlich aufgehört haben, irgendwie Geld gegen Ware immer direkt zu sehen. Also die Goldbindung von Geld war im Prinzip MEVO-Wechsel. Die Erfindung davon wurde dann... MEVO-Wechsel.
MEVO?
Das war eine Erfindung 33, mit der die Autobahnen finanziert wurden. Hat so einen, einer Yalmer Schacht erfunden und der hat damit dafür gesorgt, er hat das erste Mal Wechsel auf die Ernte vom nächsten Jahr ausgegeben. Das heißt, er hat sozusagen Geld, das der Staat damals nicht hatte, woran die Regierung vorher auch gescheitert ist, weil die Autobahnpläne gab es ja schon, aber man konnte sie nicht zahlen. Also hat er sich überlegt, wie zahlen wir die? Okay, was haben wir? Okay, wir haben ein großes Land, wir haben eine Wirtschaft, wir haben blonde Mädchen, die irgendwie draußen auf den Feldern das Stroh einsammeln und eine Ernte einfahren, wie man sich das so schön auf diesen tollen Bildern von damals irgendwie so gesehen hat. Und der ist auf die schlaue Idee gekommen, dass das ja ein Riesenwert ist und dass man auf die Wirtschaftsleistung eines Landes, nämlich also auf die Ernte des Jahres, auf die Kohleförderung, auf die Erzgewinnung, auf die produzierten Autos, auf die was auch immer, dass das der Wert ist, den ich als Sicherheit benutze, um einen Wechsel auszustellen. Und dieser Wechsel ist quasi neues Geld. Und gegen dieses neue Geld kann ich auf Basis dieses neuen Gelds druck ich dann kleine Scheine und diese kleinen Scheine gebe ich den Leuten, damit sie heute arbeiten, damit sie nächstes Jahr sich von diesen kleinen Scheinen dann ein Auto, damals noch nicht ein Auto, ein Roller, ein Fahrrad und Brot und Milch auch kaufen können. Das heißt, es wurde, also eine der großen Umstiege im Geldsystem war das Weggehen von, du gibst mir deinen Schein Papier, ich gebe dir ein Stück Gold dafür. Wurde quasi mit dem Mähvorwechsel angefangen und dann mit dem Zusammenbruch von Bretton Woods 1974, als die Amerikaner den Engländern keine 5 Milliarden Dollar in Gold ausliefern wollten, haben die einfach Bretton Woods gekündigt. Sollte man sich immer überlegen, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass der Dollar zusammenbrechen wird, die haben schon mal als ihre Leitwährung zusammengebrochen ist, einfach das System gekündigt und waren danach mehr oder weniger schuldenfrei. Bretton Woods Zusammenbruch 1974.
Okay, das ist in der Tat was, was man vielleicht mal im Internet nachlesen sollte.
Das ist durchaus ein spannendes Thema.
Wir sind zu weit, wir müssen jetzt an dieser Stelle noch mal eine kurze Pause machen.
Wir haben auch einen wunderschönen Alternativlos Podcast. Unter alternativlos.org haben sich Frank und Fefe tatsächlich mal in mehreren Stunden dieses Themas Geld und was das eigentlich ist und was daraus geworden ist und so weiter angenommen. Da wird auch noch diese Geldmengen erklärt. Das ist vielleicht noch mal ein interessanter Point da.
Okay, könnt ihr euch raussuchen. Währenddessen machen wir das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr und dann nochmal vielleicht eine halbe Stunde kriegen wir es noch geklärt, wie dann in der Zukunft die Transferleistungen aussehen. Heute Chaosradio mit Nibbler und Pluto. Hallo und willkommen zurück. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich versuche, seit anderthalb Stunden aus den Beinen rauszukriegen, wie Zahlungsmittel in Zukunft ohne Bargeld funktionieren. Das ist nicht so einfach. Ich habe heute schon gelernt, Kreditkartenübertragungen sind so la la, aber kann man schon mal machen. Es wird wahrscheinlich auf absehbare Zeit kein System geben, wo wir untereinander, also einfach sozusagen gegeneinander Geld austauschen, ohne dass irgendwie Bargeld im Spiel ist, oder noch eine Bank. Jetzt wollte ich euch einfach mal fragen, was haben wir denn noch vergessen an Zukunftsaussichten? Was gibt es da noch oder was ist da möglicherweise schon bescheitert? Ist zum Beispiel sowas wie Flatter, der von Kennern auch der Tim Pritloff Fund genannt wird, ist das ein Zahlungssystem? Dieses, man klickt im Internet auf einen Knopf, die verwalten irgendwie Bargeld, was man vorher eingezahlt hat?
Das ist ja grundsätzlich eine ganz andere Lösung für ein Problem, was man bisher immer mit Zahlungen in einer anderen Weise... Also das Problem, was Flatter löst, ist, dass Leute für immaterielle Güter größtenteils in irgendeiner Form eine Vergütung bekommen. Das ist bisher im klassischen Internet so gelaufen, wenn sowas überhaupt passiert ist mit Werbung. Also bei dem Umweg der Werbung. Also so wie wir auch das andere Radio und Fernsehen, was es da draußen gibt, bezahlen mit unseren Nerven. Ich hatte das das letzte Mal mit dem Auto im Taxi nach Tegel raus. Das ist schon ganz schön teuer. Ja, lange Rede, gar keinen Sinn. Also da wurde die Direktion bisher über Werbung gegangen, dass man halt als Produzent noch ein bisschen Fremdcontent beipackt, für den man dann bezahlt wird, den dann die Hörer oder Leser oder was auch immer erdulden müssen. Und Flutter rollt das Ganze eben andersrum auf. Da kann man als Leser sagen, okay, das hat mir gefallen, da klick ich jetzt und hab gefluttert. Und was dann am Ende des Tages oder des Monats in dem Fall passiert, ist, dass Flutter sich anguckt, okay, wie viele, wie viel Mal hat dieser Nutzer was gefluttert?
Also wir können diesen Nutzer auch benennen.
Genau.
Dieser Nutzer hat einen Namen.
Genau. Ist eindeutig identifizierbar. Und das, was dieser Nutzer in diesem Monat eingezahlt hat, wird durch alle aufgeteilt. Und jeder bekommt da, je nach Anzahl, wie häufig und überhaupt gefluttert wurde, dann seinen Teil davon. Also es ist sozusagen nicht nur Bezahlkonzept, sondern auch nochmal dieses Entlohnungsproblem. Also wie teile ich das Geld, was jemand im Monat für Immaterialgüter, die er im Internet dargeboten bekommt, ausgeben möchte, wie teile ich das auf? Das ist eine sehr spezialisierte Lösung, auch wenn Peter Sunde, der das mit ins Leben gerufen hat, jetzt schon am Überlegen ist, was man da in Zukunft noch mehr draus machen kann. Aber auch da stößt er auf das Problem, dass er da in eine Richtung gedacht hat, in die bisher so noch niemand so richtig direkt gehen wollte.
Also das Thema Micropayments für Content. Also Flutter ist schon auch Teil der Problematik, wie zahle ich im Internet zukünftig Krams? Und Content ist an der Stelle natürlich ganz weit vorne, oder Blogbeiträge, oder ich folge geben auf Twitter, und dann kann ich dem per Flutter meine Gunst erweisen und klick seinen Twitter-Account oder flettere seinen Twitter-Account. Das hat sich halt einfach noch nicht weiter durchgesetzt, was ein bisschen schade ist, weil im Prinzip ist die Idee dahintersteht schon sehr gut, aber es gibt auch ein paar Leute, die damit durchaus auch leben, und von daher ist das derzeit schon ein gültiger Marktteilnehmer. International ist es halt aktuell noch nicht so relevant.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ist ja sozusagen in Schweden, glaube ich, auch entwickelt oder Großbritannien oder wo? Und ist aber tatsächlich also ein deutscher Dienst, könnte man sagen, von den Nutzerzahlen her?
Von den Nutzerzahlen her größtenteils, ja.
Also Tim Prittlaffs Fandclub hat sich ein Vetter-Account besorgt und klickt ihn jetzt. Das kann man schon so zusammenfassen. Wenn man sich die Zahlen anguckt, irgendwie, ich hab das jetzt so im Halbjahres-Schnitt irgendwie mal gemacht, wer wieviel Flatters kriegt, ist irgendwie Tim mit 14.000 dabei, der nächste Beste ist dann Tim und der andere Moderator, der hier immer arbeitet, Holgi mit nochmal 12.000 und der nächste Beste hat dann 6.000 und das ist auch einer aus dem Chaosumfeld. Also von daher, das ist schon eine ganz gute Sache und es ist gut, dass die Leute da an der Stelle auch so viel machen und durch ihre Follower schafft dann auch tatsächlich dafür sorgen, dass so ein modernes System, um Content zu bezahlen, abseits von Werbung und direkten Zuschüssen von irgendwelchen Industrielobbyisten, die da ihre Produkte platzieren wollen oder einfach Blogger kaufen, damit sie irgendwie lustig über Sachen reden, weil sie genug Follower haben. Also es ist ein ehrliches, offenes System und es ist gut, dass es an der Stelle promotet wird. Man kann ihm nur wünschen, dass es sich weiter verbreitet. Aktuell systemrelevant wie gewisse Banken ist es halt noch nicht.
Es macht halt Mut, dass man sieht, dass so ein System, was mit einem ganz neuen Konzept daherkommt, durchaus funktionieren kann, wenn hinreichende Massanleuten sieht, okay, das ist eine interessante Lösung für das Problem. Das gab es so noch nicht. Das verwenden wir jetzt mal. Also das gibt schon Mut, da mal einen Vorstoß zu machen, um mal zu gucken. Probieren wir mal aus.
Aber haltet ihr das wirklich für zu mutig, weil ich habe eher den Eindruck bei diesem System, das funktioniert in so einem bestimmten Umfeld. Ich sag's mal, es ist eine sehr spezifische Lösung. Es ist nerdkompatibel und kommt da nicht drüber hinaus. Und was es ja auch nicht klärt, ist sozusagen, es klärt immer noch nicht das Problem, ich möchte in kleinsten Betragen elektronischer Format irgendjemand weitergeben.
Dafür gibt es eine Lösung. Die Lösung ist gerade in Arbeit und sie nennt sich Es fängt mit F an. Also wenn meine Tochter sagt, es fängt mit F an, dann weiß ich das über Fernsehen. Wenn ich jetzt sage, es fängt mit F an, wer rät das Wort? Wer hat die Lösung? Wer ist die Zukunft? Facebook ist die Lösung. Facebook ist die Zukunft. Facebook wird uns alle retten. In dem Facebook mit Paypal kooperiert für kostenlose Peer to Peer Payments, die innerhalb von Facebook realisiert werden. Und was dafür genutzt wird, sind Paypal Accounts. Und da konnte man bis jetzt ja schon, Paypal ist tatsächlich das einzige derzeit existierende Zahlungssystem, das weltweit systemrelevant ist und bei dem Peer to Peer Zahlungen möglich sind. Und das allerdings zu nicht unerheblichen Gebühren. Das heißt, von den zwei Euro, die jetzt hier für den Döner von gestern zu bezahlen wären, gehen dann, ich hab die aktuelle Preisstruktur nicht im Kopf, aber ich lass mir damit gerade für ein Buch, das ich geschrieben habe, irgendwie die Donation schicken. So eine Art Flatter-Simulation steht einfach vorne in der Einleitung drin. Wenn du das Buch gelesen hast und nichts dafür bezahlt hast wegen PDF, dann schick mir doch ein bisschen was an Paypal, das wär doch einfach nett. Und von daher sind sie da die einzige Möglichkeit, wie man sich solches Geld schicken kann, aber man muss so mit 30% Transaktionsgebühren rechnen. Und das ist natürlich für Kleinzahlungen im privaten Umfeld. Also wenn du mir gestern einen Döner ausgegeben hast und der 250 gekostet und willst mir heute das Geld wiedergeben, dann wirst du mir nicht 3, 60 Euro dafür zahlen wollen, weil du 30% draufschlagen musst, damit ich meine 250 kriege. Das heißt, das ist ganz klar, peer-to-peer ist sozusagen Micropayment ohne Transaktionsgebühr. Und deswegen interessiert es auch keinen von den großen Systemanbietern, weil wenn die Micropayment mit irgendeiner Pornosite oder mit irgendeiner Content-Site, mit der Paywall von New York Times oder Economist oder wem auch immer machen, dann haben die da einen Händler und von dem Händler können sie Prozente nehmen. Und das bringt ihnen Geld. Bei einer peer-to-peer Zahlung, niemand möchte irgendwie den Zahlungssystem aufschlag oben draufzahlen. Das wird keiner tun. Deswegen hat Facebook da jetzt eine Kooperation mit Paypal geplant. Und die wollen peer-to-peer Payments kostenlos. Das war irgendwie das Stichwort, wo ich dann bei der Pressemitteilung, die ist so 3, 4, 5 Monate alt, steht in unserem Linkbunker, ist die irgendwo drin.
Das ist natürlich für die... Also es gibt auch andere Systeme wie Moneybooker's Grill, wo man auch eine E-Mail-Adresse sozusagen Geld schicken kann. Aber die Quintessenz von so einem System ist im Prinzip, dass du als Systembetreiber und Paypal hat da eben eine gewisse Marktmacht, das Geld vom Nutzer irgendwann auch eingezahlt bekommst, damit er das weiterreichen kann. Und mit dem Geld kannst du natürlich arbeiten, weil du zahlst deinem Kunden da keine Zinsen oder sonst irgendwas, sondern im Gegenteil, kriegst du auch für irgendwelche Zahlungen, die außerhalb des Peer-to-Peer-Systems Macht Gebühren.
Aber warte mal, ich möchte mal kurz zusammenfassen. Also Facebook bietet möglicherweise das kostenlos an, dass sie wieder Geld untereinander hin- und herschieben. Und ein Geschäftsmodell für solche Anbieter könnte sein, dass sie quasi Geld durch die Zinsen machen, von einem Geld, das hochliegt.
Sie verdienen einfach dadurch, dass bei ihnen eine unglaubliche Menge an Geld liegt, können sie mit dem Geld wirtschaften. Das sehen wir auch jetzt bei eBay, die das jetzt verpflichtend machen wollen, dass man Transaktionen nicht mehr direkt abwickelt, also nicht mehr bei einer Banküberweisung, wenn man was versteigert hat, sondern dass man das Geld eBay überweist und dass die das weiter überweisen an den Verkäufer. Das führt natürlich dazu, dass von heute auf morgen Hunderte von Millionen auf eBay-Konten rumliegen. Da bin ich noch gespannt, wie schnell das Geld an die Händler weitergeht, wie da die Wertstellungstage sind, ob das nicht wirklich ein cleveres Schema ist, um einen großen Batzen an Geld, den man quasi...
Reicht da wahrscheinlich, wenn das ein paar Stunden da rumliegt bei eBay, oder?
Ja, es gibt doch in der Tageweise. Ich weiß es nicht.
Je länger, desto besser. Also es reichen auch Stunden, also im Zeiten von Pico-Sekundentrading. Es gibt tatsächlich Online-Finanztrader, die kaufen sich ihre Plätze im Rechenzentrum nach der Länge des Kabels zwischen ihrem Server und dem Anschluss an den Server von der Börse. Weil je kürzer das Kabel ist, desto schneller können sie handeln. Und es geht tatsächlich um Mikrosekunden. Teilweise, wenn es um Finanztransaktionen geht, also das System ist an der Stelle definitiv gerade extrem. Und was extrem ist, ist meistens krank, ohne das jetzt irgendwie so öffentlich gesagt haben zu wollen. Und da wird Geld sehr, sehr schnell hin und her gejagt. Das heißt, wenn ich auch nur das Geld 5 Sekunden auf meinem Konto habe, kann ich in den 5 Sekunden bereits 50 Transaktionen mit diesem Geld machen. Und 50 Transaktionen können mir bei einem durchschnittlichen Transaktionsgewinn vielleicht von 0, 3% dann schon wieder eine ganze Menge Geld einbringen. Da es in Deutschland oder weltweit keine Transaktionssteuer für solche Geldgeschäfte an den Börsen geben wird, wird das auch noch ein Weilchen existieren.
Jetzt haben wir in der Vorbereitung zu dieser Sendung, ist mir gerade aufgefallen, ist noch ein Wort gefallen, was wir noch gar nicht berücksichtigt haben. Das ist die Haftungsumkehr oder so ähnlich hieß das. Derzeit ist es ja oder wir sind es so gewohnt, wenn bei so Geldgeschäften oder Überweisungen was schief geht, dann steht die Bank dafür gerade.
Kommen wir aber gleich zum Kreditkarten. Wir haben noch irgendwas zu dem anderen Thema, weil das Haftungsumkehr ist tatsächlich was, was uns da akut ins Haus steht.
Ah ja, okay. Ich würde es gerne noch mal wenigstens kurz erwähnt haben. Wir haben nur noch zehn Minuten. Aber wenn wir noch bei dem anderen was vergessen haben, bitte.
Also vielleicht nur zu sagen, es gab früher noch sowas wie E-Gold.
Genau, da wollte ich auch gerade hin.
Ja, sag doch mal zwei Worte zu E-Gold. Ich sende mal meine Gedanken zu.
E-Gold war lustig im Sinne von, das war sozusagen mal wieder Geld gegen Gold. Also so wie es früher war, ein Schein. Und wenn ich dahin gehe und dann mein Schein auf den Tisch legt, dann kriege ich dafür eine bestimmte Menge Goldes. Das war das Geschäftsmodell dieser Firma. Und man konnte dort virtuell das Gold kaufen, das die Firma dann irgendwo eingelagert hat. Und die haben einem das garantiert, dass sie ihm das rausgeben. Man konnte denen auch Gold schicken. Und dann haben sie einem den Wert entsprechend gut gestellt. Das war auf so einer hübschen kleinen Karibikinsel. Ja ne, ich mal durch Zufall gesegelt bin, recht hübscher. Und davon war das so, beim größer an Schwarzgeldgeschäften interessierten Organisationen. Tatsächlich hat das Interesse geweckt. Und die wollten damit größere Geldmengen übertragen. Und haben sich das auch überlegt. Und denen hätte man damals nur raten müssen, Leute, wenn das das CIA nicht gegründet hat, kurz nachdem sie Facebook gegründet haben, was dann? Also ein paar Leute haben damit Geld verhandelt. Und ganz überraschend hat dann Egold auch seinen Hauptsitz nach Kalifornien verlegt. Und es kam mehr oder weniger inoffiziell raus, dass einige Mitarbeiter von Egold auch noch ein zweites Gehalt kriegen von einer amerikanischen Organisation. Und damit war die Sache dann auch geklärt. Egold ist jetzt tot, das Vertrauen war weg. Das ist halt immer das Problem, wenn ich mit solchen Systemen im Internet agiere. Und was an der Stelle, gerade weil wir es jetzt nur noch ein paar Minuten haben, das noch kurz erwähnt, noch mal mit erwähnt. Das heißt, es werden Geschäftsmodelle, Geldsysteme gegründet von privaten Firmen, die nicht in hoheitlicher Kontrolle der Staaten liegen. Das heißt, wir, das war Stevenson, irgendwie in den 80ern.
Und wir behaupten, sie legen da mal Gold in den Schrank und ist gut?
Ja, das Gold hatten sie tatsächlich. Bloß, dass sie halt nebenbei auch noch immer irgendwie ein Foto von dem Gold irgendwie an irgendwelche Leute auf dem Festland geschickt haben. Also das Geschäftsmodell war so, es gibt da auch noch einen Scheich, der will das auch machen. Ach nee, das mit dem Scheich, das stammt tatsächlich aus Kryptonomiken. Also alles, was man in die Richtung sagen kann, liest Stevenson, liest Wörner-Winch, weil da sind die Sachen tatsächlich gut vorhergesagt worden. Inklusive des Betrugs, den die E-Gold-Firma dann hinterher an den Kunden begangen hat. Selbst dies im Kryptonomiken schon vorhergesagt. Also soviel zum Thema lustige Systeme, wo man hier Geld einzahlt, so Western Union etc. das kann man ja nicht als Internetgeld sehen, obwohl die auch intern elektronisch Hand haben. Da ist die Frage, was fällt da rein? Also was man auf jeden Fall noch mit erwähnen sollte, weil das gerade eine der großen Revolutionen im Bankensystem ist und weil es auch alles elektronisch läuft, ist die Wiege der Menschheit hat was Neues erfunden, nämlich das Handybanking. Also das hat angefangen mit einer Bank, die Micro-Lending, also sprich Mini-Kredite an Pharma gegeben haben. Also wirklich ein Kredit für eine Schubkarre. Da konnte man denen irgendwie eine SMS schicken und sagen, ich bin der sowieso und ich brauch eine Schubkarre, dann kann ich mehr Reis anbauen und dann geht's meiner Familie besser und meine Kinder müssen nicht mehr hungern. Und die haben dann das Geld für die Schubkarre überwiesen, haben sich die Telefonnummer von den Menschen gemerkt und dann hat er angefangen jeden Monat irgendwie drei Reiskörner abzuzahlen und über drei Jahre hat er die Schubkarre wieder finanziert und natürlich dreimal repariert. Und das hat relativ gut funktioniert. Das war ein Riesenerfolg für die Entwicklungshilfe. Und aus diesem Schema hat sich jetzt mittlerweile zusammen halt auch so mit Telefon-Guthabenkarten ein komplettes eigenes Banking-System entwickelt, wo die Leute in kleinen Fischerdörfern, wo es echt nichts gibt, außer so einer älteren Dame, die mit ihrem Handy da sitzt und darauf wartet, dass jemand kommt. Und meistens ist da mittlerweile sogar eine Schlange. Der gibt den Menschen Cash, die tippt in ihr Handy ein. Handy-Nummer sowieso hat mir gerade gegeben 3000 Yuan. Oder wie auch immer das da heißt.
Oder generell die Verrechnung von Beträgen über prepaid-Karten-Guthaben. Also in den, ja, konnten...
Ganz nach der Vorläufer.
In Ländern wie Indien haben die Leute halt hauptsächlich prepaid-Karten und da gab es die Möglichkeit, zwischen den Kartenkonten der einzelnen prepaid-Karten Geld hin und her zu buchen. Das hat in letzter Konsequenz Indien dazu geführt, dass alle prepaid-Karten für mobile Telefone, also wirklich zum Telefonieren, das war das selbe Konto, wie wir das Telefonieguthaben, dass die alle registriert werden mussten. Also man musste dann Ausweis usw. und wirklich Registrierungen. Sie haben da sehr viele Karten abgeschaltet nach der Deadline, die nicht registriert waren. Da war ja natürlich der Staat auch wieder auf den Geldtransfer da seine Finger drauf bekommen wollte.
Auch wieder die Kontrolle und Überwachung. Das ist halt bei diesem neuen Banking-System, also bei diesem Handy-Banking, das sich da gegeben hat, sozusagen mit kaum ausgebildeten Leuten, die einfach da sitzen, mit dem Handy Geld annehmen und jemanden sagen, ich hab jetzt das Geld und ein paar Sekunden später kann der per SMS dann tatsächlich das Geld an jemand anders wieder in kleineren Stücklungen weitergeben. Das ist ja auch immer ganz wichtig, dass wenn ich Geld in einem Betrag X kriege, dass ich das wieder stückelen kann in kleinere Beträge und dann diese kleineren Beträge weitergeben kann. Deswegen ist man ja mal vom Tauschhandel mit ganzen Kühen abgekommen.
Hier haben sie eine Hufe. So, jetzt noch kurz, bevor Flo Heiler kommt und euch im Neidfeld mit Punk-Musik bewirft, würde ich gerne noch mal mit dem Haftungsumkehr...
Die Beweislastumkehr.
Die Beweislastumkehr bei der Haftung, genau.
Da sind wir jetzt tatsächlich wieder bei den Kreditkarten. Nämlich das heiße Neue, was jetzt kommt, ist Mastercard 3D Secure. Und ich weiß nicht, wie das Produkt von Visa heißt. Ja, lange Rede, gar keinen Sinn. Du bekommst nicht mehr nur die Nummer, die hinten und vorne auf deiner Karte drauf steht, wobei die hinten auf der Karte nicht gespeichert werden darf und die vorne und so weiter. Sondern du bekommst, wie auf einer schlechten Fishing Website, die versucht irgendwelche Daten von dir abzuziehen, eine Einblendung, dass du dich da doch bitte anmelden sollst.
Wo jetzt? Auf dem Automaten?
Nie, bei einer Online-Bezahlung. Also du kriegst deine Kreditkarten-Dings rein, deine CVV, und dann kriegst du nochmal ein Pop-Up oder ein Iframe mit etwas, was so tut, als wärst du eine Banken-Website, wo du dir auch nicht so richtig sicher sein kannst. Sieht auf jeden Fall rein, von der Psychologie her kommt das halt schon an einer Fishing Website, die irgendwelche Accountdaten abziehen möchte, sehr ähnlich. Und da musst du dich halt nochmal authentifizieren mit Benutzernahme, Passwort oder so. Und das Bemerkenswerte daran ist, nicht, dass sie irgendwie ein Sicherheitsmerkmal einführen, was so aussieht wie eine Fishing Website, sondern dass im gleichen Schritt in den Geschäftsbedingungen zu der Karte die Beweislast umgekehrt wird. Bisher kannst du zu deinen Kreditkarten-Dings hingehen und sagen, hier die Karte, da hab ich nicht verwendet. Weiß ich nicht, kann ich nicht zuordnen, mach mal Chargeback bitte. Bei dieser 3D-Secure-Geschichte ist es halt so, dass den Nachweis, dass du das nicht warst, weil das ist jetzt ja viel sicherer, den Nachweis musst du erbringen. Du kannst da jetzt nicht einfach sagen, ne, das war ich nicht, da hat irgendjemand im Internet meine Daten geklaut und da können wir uns genau ausrechnen, was passiert, weil diese Seite ist genauso eine Seite, wo man seine Daten eingibt und ob ich jetzt meine Kreditkartennummer eingebe oder meine Kreditkartennummer, ein Benutzernamen und ein Passwort, ist am Ende des Tages für den Angreifer kein großer Unterschied.
Ist das zum ersten Mal versucht worden, also diese Beweislastumkehr auf den Kunden abzuwälzen?
Das ist...
Weil ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass gerade so jemand wie die Bankenindustrie das schon mal häufiger probiert hat.
Also gerade die EC-Karten haben da eine schöne Historie von Beweisungen, dass der PIN-Brief echt nicht geöffnet war. Und gerade die EC-Karten haben da die schöne Historie, da gab es dann auch so Fälle, wo eine Oma den PIN-Brief tatsächlich irgendwie ungeöffnet zu Hause hat und ihr dann vorlegen konnte, irgendwie... So seltsame Vorfälle sind aber auch alle schon größer 10 Jahre hier.
Ja, also es ist im Prinzip tatsächlich vergleichbar mit der PIN-Geschichte. Also in dem Moment, wo du eine PIN an einem Terminal verwendest, ist ja auch die Haftungsumkehr, also EMV, bei Karte und Online an der Stelle. Also Karte in ein Terminal reinschieben, PIN eingeben. Bist du auch in der Nachweispflicht, dass du das an der Stelle nicht warst, dass du deine PIN aufgehoben hast und so weiter. Das ist da natürlich noch mal was anderes. Bei so einem Terminal, ja, natürlich gibt's da Sicherheitsschwankungen. Natürlich gibt's irgendwie den einen oder anderen Fall, wo es so ein Terminal gegeben hat, dass kein echtes war, sondern die Daten mitgeschrieben und an das Echte weitergereicht hat und so weiter. Aber bei der Online-Verwendung ist halt das Risikopotential um ein vierfaches höher, weil ja, Sicherheit auf Computern ist halt einfach nicht gegeben. Ist halt so, muss man sagen. Ein schönes Großteil der Felder der Computer da draußen. Ich würde auf dem Computer, den meine Eltern haben, meine Daten nicht eingeben wollen, weil ich nicht weiß, was die alle anklicken. Und selbst mein Notebook vertraue ich nur...
So weit, wie du es schmeißen kannst?
Nicht so weit, wie ich es schmeißen, aber man hat halt schon ein schlechtes Gefühl dabei, wenn man weiß, okay, das ist jetzt nicht mehr so eine Transaktion, wo ich sagen kann, bisher verwende ich meine Kreditkarte super gerne im Internet und gar kein Problem. Und trallala, bis ja auch zum Glück noch nichts passiert. Aber ich weiß, wenn irgendwas passiert, kann ich ein Chargeback machen und sagen, hm, war nicht, weil, dit und dit. Aber ja, mit Verified by Visa heißt das eine und 3D Secure ist das Ganze eben umgedreht. Und da bin ich dann halt wirklich in der Bredouille, wenn meine Kartendaten und das benutzende Passwort wegkommt.
Aber das wird natürlich nie passieren. Ich muss sagen, ich fand die Sendung heute ein bisschen frustrierend, denn ich habe vor allem zwei Sachen gelernt. A, es wird immer schlimmer für mich als Kunden. Möglicherweise muss ich demnächst noch beweisen, dass ich nicht Schindlula mit meiner Karte getrieben habe. Und B, eine echte digitale Ablösung des Bargeldes ist derzeit nicht am Horizont zu sehen, vor allem, weil es da keine wirtschaftlichen Interessen gibt. Falls ihr eine Idee habt, wie man das umsetzen kann, schreibt mir gerne eine Mail. Pluto Nibbler, vielen Dank fürs Dabeisein.
Hat noch eine Anekdote los, wer?
Alter, wenn der Flo jetzt reinkommt und dich vom Stuhl schubs, dann hab ich dich vorher gewarnt.
Bezahlterminis, modifizierte Bezahlterminis. Also da gab es tatsächlich eine Serie, die von Abwerk aus China kamen, die modifiziert waren. Und zwar so, dass sie, also selbst der Händler das nicht wusste, und diese die Daten über ein GSM-Modul nach Hause geschickt haben, also die Kartendaten und die PIN und so weiter. Gemerkt hat man es dann durch wiegen und seitdem wird halt alles auf die Goldwaage gelegt.
Also Leute, wiegt eure Kartenlesegeräte.
Großflächige Nachwiegeaktionen von Kartenterminals.
Sollte man immer mal machen, sein Kartenterminal wiegen. Außerdem, lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups.